Let's consider a
system in which there
is no non-conservative
work and there's
a potential energy associated
with forces in the system.
And for an example,
let's model some system
by the following
function b x-cubed.
And we know that our
definition of force
is that it's minus the
change in potential energy.
So if we differentiate this,
our force is a function of x.
And because of that
minus sign, you always
have to be careful when you
take that type of derivative,
we get as far as the force
goes, 2ax minus 3b x-squared.
Now we ask ourselves, where
does this force vanish?
So if we look at the 0
points for the force,
we can see immediately that
there is one x equals 0.
The other one, if we said
2ax equals a 3b x-squared
tells us that we have another 0
point at 2/3 over 2/3 a over b.
Now let's also for example,
just put some numbers in.
For some simplicity, let's
write this as 4 joules per meter
squared for a.
Why do we have meter squared?
Well, the units of
potential energy are joules,
and we're multiplying
by x-squared.
And so you can see
that d also we're
going to write as 2
joules metered to minus 3.
And if we put those
numbers in, we
can see that we'll get 8 over 6.
And 8 over 6 is just 4/3,
and that will be in meters
where the other 0 point is.
So that's nice, but we'd like
to do some properties of these 0
points.
If we had a particle that
we started with some energy
at one 0 point,
where would it go?
What would it do
at the other point?
So in order to understand
a little bit more
detail about these
0 points, let's
make a plot of our potential
energy U of x verse x.
Now to begin with, we
want to ask ourselves
how does this function behave?
And for big values of x, the
x cube piece will dominate.
And if we're positive x, we
dominate with a negative value
for potential energy.
So our potential energy function
goes off into negative infinity
as x goes to infinity.
Now on the other
side of the scale,
the x-cubed term will dominate
for negative values of x.
But this term is negative,
and that's negative,
so up here it will
go off to infinity
in the positive direction.
Now, where are the zeroes
of the potential function?
There's obviously
one at x equals 0.
And with these values, it's
not 100% obvious immediately,
but 4x squared
minus 2b x-cubed--
if you set x equal to 2, 4 times
2 is 8, b 2 times 2, 4 times
4 is 16.
If b is 2 and x is 2, that's 16.
So we get a cancellation
at x equals 2.
And so we have a point up here.
I'm sorry, that's our
0 point at x equals 2.
Now, we said that the force
at x equals 4/3 had a 0.
And so if we plot
this function, it's
going to look
something like that.
Now, let's focus
on these two points
right here where our force is 0.
Remember, that this
is minus the slope.
And so we can see
immediately that these two
points have 0 slope and
so the force is 0 there.
Notice, potential energy always
depends on a reference point.
So whether the potential energy
is 0 or not is not crucial.
But the physical fact that
the force 0 there has physical
mean.
So here this is one of
our points F of x is 0.
Now, what is the
property of this point?
Well, suppose we ask ourselves
if the particle were just
displaced slightly
from this position
where the force is 0, which
way would the force point?
Well in order to answer
a question like that,
we can look at the slopes
on either side of the 0.
So over here the
slope is negative,
but the force is
minus the slope.
So F of x is positive
on this side.
And so if a particle is
displaced a little bit
from the 0 point, it
moves off to the right,
and it will continue to feel
a force in this direction,
and so it will move away from
the 0 point of the force.
Now on the other side, we do
the same type of argument.
And over here the
slope is positive,
but the force is negative.
So again, what we
see on this side,
the particle will move
away from this 0 point.
And so if our particle
just started there
and it had a little
bit of kinetic energy,
it would move one way or the
other away from that point.
And so we call this an
unstable equilibrium point.
And that's an abbreviation
for equilibrium.
Now, what about this
0 point over here?
Well, we already know
that if a particle is
on this side of the 0 it
feels the force this way.
But what if our particle
were on this side?
Well, once again, we
analyze the slope.
The slope is negative,
force is minus the slope,
so it's positive.
So everywhere on this
side, the particle
is getting a restoring
force back to equilibrium.
And so if we displace
this particle just
on either side, if it
doesn't have enough energy
to get over this point,
then the particle
will stay around this area.
And that is why we give
this point the name
of stable equilibrium point.